es geht in den Iran Straßenkämpfe
Proteste Gewalt genau hier seit 12 Tagen
seit fast zwei Wochen Frauen reißen sich
ihre Tücher vom Kopf verbrennen sie aber
warum passiert das alles gerade jetzt
warum eskaliert die Situation warum
gehen plötzlich tausende junge Frauen
und Männer im Iran auf die Straße es
beginnt alles mit einem tragischen Tod
der Tod von Mascha Amini einer
22-jährigen Frau
[Musik]
mutige Frauen im Iran verbrennen ihre
Kopftücher das Zeichen jahrzehntelanger
Unterdrückung es geht in Flammen auf
Bilder die um die Welt gehen
seit zwei Wochen gehen Menschen im Iran
auf die Straße sind Männer und Frauen in
Aufruhr Frauen schneiden sich aus
Protest die Haare ab
Auslöser ist der gewaltsame Tod von
Mascha Amini die 22-Jährige war Mitte
September von den iranischen
Sittenwächtern festgenommen worden weil
ihr Kopftuch angeblich nicht richtig saß
nach ihrer Verhaftung fällt Mascha
armini plötzlich ins Koma stirbt kurz
darauf im Krankenhaus
seit ihrem Tod Gerät das islamistische
molaregime immer stärker unter Druck
überall im Land gehen Iranerinnen und
Iraner auf die Straße wütende Proteste
in mindestens 46 Städten
mutige Proteste gegen die Unterdrückung
gegen das unterdrückerische
müller-regime mit brutaler Härte gehen
die Sicherheitskräfte gegen die
Freiheitskämpfer vor schlagen auf sie
ein Schießen mit scharfer Munition in
die Menge
verhaften tausende schalten das Internet
im Land ab um den Protest
niederzukämpfen die brennenden
Kopftücher im Iran
eindrucksvolles Symbol für den mutigen
Kampf gegen das islamische Regime
[Musik]
[Applaus]
den Kampf für die Freiheit bezahlen
viele mit dem Leben bislang soll es
mindestens 76 Tote geben
der Kampf gegen jahrzehntelange
Unterdrückung weckt auch die Hoffnung
dass das mularegime ins Wanken gerät
dass dies der Anfang vom Ende ist das
Ende der autoritären Müller Machthaber
in Teheran
aber nicht nur der Iran macht mobil auch
sie hier wollen ein Zeichen setzen gegen
die Diktatur und vor allem auch und die
gegen die Unterdrückung von Frauen im
Iran in Berlin am Brandenburger Tor fast
2.000 Menschen demonstrieren hier
friedlich ohne Gewalt aber deutlich
gegen das mulla-regime mit dabei unter
anderem auch viele Politiker wie
Landwirtschaftsminister Cem Özdemir und
Menschenrechtsaktivistin düsentag es
macht Mut es macht mir aber auch
wahnsinnig Hoffnung ich hoffe dass die
Menschen nicht nur heute kommen sondern
auch morgen und übermorgen und die
Menschen auch immer unterstützen im Iran
bis sie ihre Freiheit endlich erlangt
haben das ist ganz wichtig dass wir
nicht nur einmal jetzt vor kurzem
mediale Aufmerksamkeit da ist auf die
Straßen gehen sondern immer man tut er
doch ich habe selbst zwei Töchter die
könnten die zukünftigen masers sein sie
werden im Iran keine Sicherheit haben
deswegen bin ich hier für die
zukünftigen masers damit sie in Frieden
und Freiheit leben und zwar haben wir
help geht's eigentlich darum
immer wieder dafür zu sensibilisieren
dass frauenrechtsverletzung und
Menschenrechtsverletzungen universell
sind und dass wir uns viel mehr dafür
interessieren müssen was auch über die
europäischen nestrengender hinaus
passiert im Iran werden Frauenrechte
sehr sehr lange schon unterdrückt aber
seit 43 Jahren staatlich organisiert und
die letzten Proteste des immer gegeben
hat gegen der Luftverschmutzung gegen
Dürre gegen gefälschte Wahlen gegen
Korruption die wurden immer von Frauen
getragen aber diesmal ist es anders weil
Frauen führen diese Demonstrationen
dieser Proteste an Angst haben wir also
vor allem diejenigen die noch Familie im
Iran haben bei mir ist gerade auch der
Fall
ich bin Sängerin also ich war schon
immer ein Problem für islamischer
Republik also deswegen ich habe schon
lange aufgegeben für lange Zeit Iran und
meine Familie zu sehen mindestens emiran
ich habe versucht meine Mutter zu
erreichen das Internet ist bei uns
abgeschaltet ich kann sie nicht
erreichen ich weiß nicht wie es meiner
Mutter geht meine Tochter kann auch in
Zukunft so was im vorkommen und wie muss
ich dann die sind hier zu uns mit unsere
Stimmung zeigen es sollte einfach
gestoppt werden
Frauenrechte
lgbtqi-rechte Meinungsfreiheit
Pressefreiheit das ist eine westliche
Erfindung ist es nicht es sind
universelle Menschenrechte die stehen in
der Karte hat der Vereinten Nationen so
von gelten sind heran genauso wie in
Hongkong sie müssen in St Petersburg
genauso Geld wie in Moskau
es ist Katastrophe also die Leute zu
sehen es ist egal ob Iraner sind oder
nicht Iraner einfach die Leute die nicht
in der Hand haben und fröhlich postieren
protestieren möchten so abzuschlachten
ich glaube wenn man ein bisschen Emotion
ein bisschen menschlich sein kann dann
kann man sowas nicht sehen es ist sehr
es tut richtig weh es tut sehr weh und
zu dem Thema begrüßen wir jetzt bei uns
im Studio FDP Generalsekretär
bijanjiasaray schönen guten Tag schön
dass Sie da sind guten Morgen ich grüße
sie stammen selbst aus dem Iran für wie
durchsetzungsstark halten Sie diese
Protestbewegung also zunächst einmal
diese Demonstration sind anders als in
der Vergangenheit bis jetzt war es so
dass die Menschen in den letzten Jahren
immer auf der Straße waren um nach
Reformen zu verlangen das ist jetzt
anders die Menschen im Iran fordern
keine Reformen für die Islamische
Republik also keine Reform der
islamische Republik sondern die Menschen
im Iran fordern heute die Abschaffung
der Islamischen Republik und das so ein
riesen Unterschied wie groß ist die
Gefahr dass weitere Proteste jetzt von
geheimdienst-
ich gehe fest davon aus dass das bereits
stattfindet das wird es ist übrigens
auch möglich dass die Demonstrationen
niedergeschlagen werden in den nächsten
Tagen aber das werden die mullas nicht
mehr im Griff bekommen denn ein paar
Tage später paar Wochen später eine
andere Stadt eine andere Region das wird
immer wieder losgehen die Menschen sind
jetzt auf der Straße sie Menschen wollen
Veränderungen sie die Menschen wollen
Freiheit und das werden die mullas auf
Dauer nicht unterdrücken können vor
einigen Tagen haben sie gesagt die
Politik der EU gegenüber dem Iran seiner
Eve warum haben sie das gesagt ich sage
das seit vielen vielen Jahren und wir
haben das ja in der Vergangenheit gehört
auch in einem anderen Zusammenhang dass
man gesagt hat die Politik gegenüber
Russland in den letzten Jahren mal
falsch und naiv und genauso ist es auch
beim Thema Iran
die sowohl die Europäische Union und das
gilt auch für die deutsche Außenpolitik
der letzten Jahre man hat in
Zusammenhang mit dem Iran nur über das
atomabkommen gesprochen man hat nicht
über die Rolle des Relevanz in der
Region gesprochen das ist keine
konstruktive Rolle man hat nicht über
das iranische Raketenprogramm gesprochen
und vor allem man hat nie über die
eklatanten Menschenrechtsverletzungen im
Iran gesprochen ich finde es ist eine es
ist eine höchste Zeit dass diese Politik
sich ändert wir brauchen eine neue Iran
Strategie sowohl in der Europäischen
Union als auch in Deutschland wie sieht
die Iran Strategie aus was fordern Sie
ganz konkret also zunächst einmal
brauchen wir personenbezogene Sanktionen
gegenüber den Vertretern dieses Regimes
denn sie dürfen nicht vergessen die
Leute die für Menschenrechtsverletzungen
im Iran verantwortlich sind können bis
zum heutigen Tag frei Reisen durch
Europa übrigens auch diese Leute kommen
auch nach Deutschland haben konnten
haben ganze Reihe von Freiheiten die ihr
ihre Landsleute im Iran nicht haben also
hier personenbezogene Sanktionen wir
wollen mit Sanktionen nicht die Menschen
im Iran bestrafen sondern wir wollen die
Führung der islamische Republik
bestrafen und natürlich das Thema
atomabkommen also JCA
reicht nicht dass man permanent nur über
dieses atomabkommen redet sondern dazu
gehören auch andere Komponenten die ich
auch vorhin erwähnt habe vor allem dass
das Thema Menschenrechte jetzt im Fokus
der Iran Politik steht wir brauchen eine
neue Iran Strategie sagt
FDP-Generalsekretär wie shanjas Saray
vielen vielen Dank dass Sie heute
Vormittag bei uns war herzlichen Dank
[Musik]